jean claude van damme vous êtes né plane
pee wee vous été en 1960 donc en
belgique
votre père était libraire et puis
ensuite fleuriste et c'est vrai que
votre mère vendait des soutiens-gorge
way est très longtemps dans une rue de
flandre dans le quartier des marolles un
quartier très pauvre
nous tiendrons assez chétif chétif vaste
algique pas du tout le genre de van
damme qu'on connaît aujourd'hui anxieux
en ce sens toujours plongé dans les
livres
et quand je suis venu en amérique parce
que bon j'ai fait du sport mon père m'a
appris à l'âge très jeune à l'âge de 11
ans aime rire du karaté vu que j'ai fait
pas tellement fort physiquement et j'ai
pu me développer mentalement et
physiquement grâce au karaté merci ça
c'est que votre père quand j'avais 12
ans vous emmène son enclos de goethe
entraîneur de karaté et là au début vous
êtes un peu raide un peu craintif mais
vous avez une volonté une volonté d'en
faire moi j'ai progressé très déterminé
vous souffrez vous abandonner mais
toujours vous revenez comme ça m'est un
peu violent envers de la faire de la
musculation et la sortie vous êtes un
champion de karaté à l'âge de l'âge de
17 ans précise un champion d'europe en
79 et champion du monde à waco en
floride et les virus de l'amérique à ce
moment là s'ils voulaient absolument
aller habiter aux états unis depuis
longtemps un depuis l'âge ne fait pas à
l'âge de 16 17 ans je rêvais d'amérique
pourquoi je ne sais pas c'est à dire que
je crois que dans la vie on a tous une
mission à faire et c'était pour moi
j'avais j'avais cette histoire
d'amérique dans la peau depuis le matin
jusqu'au soir le film est toujours rêver
d'amérique
je suis parti en amérique et j'ai tenté
ma chance pour ouais alors 83 vous
commencez à faire du cinéma vous jouer
un petit rôle dans rue barbare de gilles
béhat vétéran ray du film avant pourquoi
j'étais arrivé un jour trop tard
il m'avait dit je dis souvent je sais
pas quoi je suis règles train j'étais
sur le set à 3-2 matin j'attendais quand
il ya un problème je suis parti à fond
de téléphone maddin espèce de conte et
belges et tout cela il m'a dit tu feras
jamais du cinéma tu as raté
je suis qu'est ce que j'ai fait en
france j'ai brûlé ma carte 1 a jamais eu
peur après vous repartez donc à los
angeles alors vous parlez pas anglais
vous n'êtes pas de carte de travail et
puis à des milliers d'américains qui
vont à son jeu laisse pour pour faire
fortune dans cinéma qui ont le même rêve
que vous les millions dont il vous
faudra huit ans pour vous en sortir
l'art vous êtes vendeur de pizza videur
de boîte de nuit chauffeur de limousine
rapide la fête tous les boulots quoi
ouais le pire boulot vous ayez fait
c'est quoi attendre ouais
le chauffeur de limousine le travail
c'est super quand une mission dans la
vie et qu'on veut faire quelque chose et
on pense sourire on pense à as to be je
dois être un acteur on peut émettre bits
ou rave
je suis un acteur je suis allé je
travaille protecteur et le havre déjà
partie sept à bruxelles
alors quand j'ai montré que j'étais
acteur même les pizzas que je les livrer
au jeu
des vitesses que tu veux j'avais j'étais
acteur dans ma tête j'ai réussi un et
alors qu'on pense comme ça dans la vie
c'est pour tout le monde pour tous les
français pour tous les belges pour le
monde entier
quand vraiment une confiance ou un twist
ou d'olive de bonif camp est confiante à
la confiance on devient confiant sur
cette mission il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent un jour peut-être que je sache à
sa fin qui se passe ouais fautes
personnelles nom prénom d'accord avec la
gauche
alors on fait plein de boulot donc vous
êtes chauffeur de limousine et vous
dites que vous avez beaucoup appris en
conduisant des petits cons plein de
pognon qu'ils se foutaient en l'air avec
de la drogue nous a pas empêchés de
faire pareil après maintenant et pendant
des années donc vous essayer de
rencontrer des producteurs des acteurs
êtes le genre de mec un peu collant faut
dire la vérité si achevé sa tournée les
mecs sur les parkings des acteurs les
producteurs mais c'était avant la drogue
oui bien sûr important mais c'est bien
plus tard quand on fait des corps en
fait de la drogue ont fait plus que
votre quelle voiture c'est et qu'elle
admet qu'on a parlé ya un truc qui se
passe là donc vous allez mettre des
tracts sous les pare brise et que votre
nom votre numéro de téléphone et ou êtes
le genre de mec un peu collant quand
même pas colin insistant avec très
insistants un collant si on investit
coeur ouais mais c'est une cache
l'épaule il parce qu'avec vous l'enlever
elle a déchiré non vers la classe quoi
au fait aussi le siège dans le wall
marais vous faites aussi le siège des
domiciles des stars donc stallone
scharzenegger chuck norris et un jour
décidé de tenter le tout pour le tout il
ya un producteur qui s'appelle menahem
golan et vous lui faites à la sortie
d'un restaurant un bar when she c'est
quoi un match y est relié montreuil
je n ai pas peur je vais faire notamment
un chien fou mais aussi caméra l'a bien
ici j'ai tout à l'heure on n'est pas moi
je ne joue pas encore battant c'est un
marcheur
bah ouais alors j'ai fait comme ça j'ai
vu madame m la voilà ça prendra plus que
c'est un peu technique mais je resterai
avait surclassé l'arête du nez
moi je connais les gars je m'empresse de
distance
c'était la sortie d'un restaurant donc
la victime était en arrêt no dolan donc
est un grand producteur de cinéma
américain à l'époque à l'époque a
entendu et le lendemain et nous invite
au bureau il vous fait attendre pendant
six heures et au bout de six heures vous
rentrez dans son bureau et vous lui
faites un grand écart entre deux chaises
ouais ayé c'était plus que ça d'abord
j'ai et j'essaie de me de me vendre vite
avant d'heure maintenant même est un
vendeur sait pas c'est pas un producteur
à la halle à jerry bruckheimer km 110
milliards pour un film lui téléfilm pour
4 millions $ et les vents pour 6,7
décemment d'heure hockey alors j'entends
aller les vendeurs parler de gauche à
droite georges à me vendre
excusez moi alors je suis rentré dans le
fils et je le porte-clés oui ouais super
comme mec est très intelligent et quoi
aussi d'ailleurs et alors quand je
rentre alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai parlé
je pars bla bla bla bla bla j'ai fait
ceci et puis je cause a break dans cette
manche ici j'en peux plus
mais les sept ans que je suis là j'en
peux plus je n'en peux plus je n'en peux
plus m'arrêter
soixante ans c'est très très bien la
vérité est ce qu'il y à rien de venir
lundi que dire la vérité
1 quand tu dis est la vérité benjamin
lemaire programme la fin des discussions
à tous ces natures et alors c'est passé
il a craqué pour moi le hockey tu fais
de beaux scores telle carte verte
j'ai dit ouais bien sûr ce pas alors je
dis on avoue t elle
heureusement que le film s'est fait en
com - là j'étais sauvée à cause de
l'immigration via son assistante qui
s'appelait kelly apporte mois d'août
sport qui était le synopsis du film et
vous a dit you want to be used as almac
houston
voilà ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
jean-claude c'est quand le film est
terminé
menahem golan il ne trouve pas terrible
il directement le vendre en vidéo en
cassette sans passer par les le problème
salle de cinéma
le problème c'est important qu'on
producteurs et il ya le découpage d'un
fils
oui alors quand on fait un coup de pied
comme jeter c'est là et qu'on le
découvre au milieu et on va sur un
closet d'acino d'iférouane et puis qu'on
revient sur moi et on va nous coûter les
jours un très grand peuple
mais justement ce qui se passe et ils
ont découpé alors se passer si je vois
des coupes et leighlin géré découper le
film ce soir à ma manière à moi le mieux
que j'avais voilà ce que je faisais là
j'étais reparti au à musina nerveux
comme dégroupage chalifoux moi la paix
retourne en belgique qui vous être non
pas comme ça alors après le film est
sorti si ces deux mois après et grâce à
la france la france grâce à monsieur
samuel hadida mon pote il a distribué de
sport en france sa femme à l'heure voilà
et donc après on a appelé aux états unis
jean claude van damme de me seul chrome
brussels
ce qui veut dire les muscles de
bruxelles c'est moi qui gère les mouches
voilà j'ai mais voilà j'y pense et je me
sens
ça veut dire je vous salue bien souvent
incroyables en anglais commençaient mal
c'est de là que le service public on
apprend les lieux projet voilà
maintenant je me sens déjà beaucoup
mieux le français va déjà mieux non oui
beaucoup mieux que ça m'arrive en écoute
à l'heure jojo attention vous enchaînez
avec une série de succès énorme succès
pour pouvoir pour l'investissement
ouais super parce que je peux regarder
tous les studios dans les yeux le seul
acteur au monde et je le dis encore
maintenant chaque producteur je peux et
j'ai jamais interdit en france aucun des
films et non ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils
veulent il ya aucun de mes films qu'ils
apprenaient à francs auxquels les films
pas un centime ils ont tous les deux de
l'argent pour les studios pour m même
les génère mal et génère et là ils
étaient pris en vidéo en france les gens
l'adorent mais c'est différent et blanc
qui bloque qui bloque les rôles c'est
comme réplique en répliquant cette page
une déclaration
ça va être un beau y aura de l'action
d'accord mais c'est un film c'est
dramatique c'est autre chose
mais les gens ils ont une image james
bond ça a pris chan qu'on arrive à temps
pour changer james bond de become de
sexe jusqu'à alors les gens quand ils
ont une image fixe et sur quelqu'un il
reste sur la bible ou le coran
oui comme les religions doit on va pas
en parler mais je dire que qu' il faut
il faut un peu avec ces images c'est
normal
non mais j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui
qu'il fait dans la vie il faut être là
et j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui que
passer pour un héros sa maîtresse et une
plaie non ses impressions vous avez -
vous êtes malade dans un mois ou trois
business à la pieuvre de limiter la
pression médiatique je viens ici parce
qu'on m'a vite
j'aime bien mon public français ce
qu'ils m'ont fait
là
ouais dieu
mesbah
j'ai pas mes sculptures qui m'ont fait
parce qu'alors il ya une histoire qui se
passe dans le monde du cinéma ce qu'est
ce que c'est super quand tu fais un film
est une réussite et nouveau major studio
là le manque je vais 10 trouver demand
jeunes disent les uns
du coup c'est nouveau le mec est bien et
puisse y aller par l'allemagne et alaska
joe johnson
mais si je m'intéresse pas à l'âge de 42
ans
et là je mène dans le business autre
chose un pour l'instant alors il ya
aussi des problèmes j'ai eu des
problèmes lé problème c'est bien non bon
il ya eu la coke un peu quoi la côte et
les mecs là qu il ya un monsieur qu'elle
soit arrêtée quand le régime a été
lourde et nous la coque la coff la cour
la corde
il n'y a pas plus merdique l'assaut
jamais d'en prendre une claque et ça
arrête la tête du foot ou en l'air je
sais si c'est parce qu'on dira c'est
parce qu on est d'accord
alors on est très d'accord la courbe
faut pas toucher de la mer voilà j'ai
essayé moi de l'abattre on peut pas
l'abattre alors elle devient quand la
connais elle devient un compagnon qu'on
touche pas allergique à la cour c'est
très simple et c'est pour ça que je sais
parler maintenant je suis en forme j'ai
peur de personne qui fera les yeux tu
m'as tu côtoies bon je prends un peu 8
c'est un problème non rapide jamais
dérapé c'est pourquoi je mange des
légumes est en pleine forme et je suis
versé
la raison la course maintenant
l'accaparent s'ils savent s'ils peuvent
en rire de fifteen là un an copains ici
à la ba et met toi mais vont prendre un
mec comme moi et vous m'accusez parce
qu'ils ont de la petit poisson comme ça
qu'on lui connaît alors comme robert
downey junior et dans le froid des gens
comme ça il secoue un peu pour les
commerciale bien dans les journaux à ce
que la moitié de l'amérique c'est les
banques et tous ont fait de cause les
effets durent tout investissement
c'est quoi mais tout le bonheur
parallèle ces bilans darveau chez vous
chez nous mais qui a vendu les abris
anti atomiques en irak qui j'ai pas dans
ses bras on fait en même temps que nous
ferons en même temps c'est vrai nous ça
ne change pas le monde et par jour et il
a changé sur un bien il faut montrer la
violence
non parce que parce qu'on fait partie
d'un monde de violence et on peut pas
dire aux enfants quand ils vont dans la
rue ce bon ben on va dire à des gens
dans la rue se vêtent disneyland pour
voter mais vous adorez non il faut dire
à l'enfant qui a de la mer dans la rue
il ya de la coquille à ceux ci à cela il
ya beaucoup de danger c'est la jungle
alors on est d'accord
alors non le vrai problème c'est surtout
que les bons scripts
ils vont plutôt chez tom cruise et
pourtant on vous dit je suis prêt à
tourner gratuitement avec un réalisateur
que j'admire vais certainement jamais
métier bien sûr oui vite maintenant
attention ça a changé
j'aimerais faire un film sur la vie de
jacques brel je suis trop trop trop trop
barak et voilà c'est un nom si je tombe
malade
projetons pas de problème de carrière
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça finalement
c'est je les envie de faire des films de
meilleure qualité avec des meilleurs
réalisateurs
non non j'aime bien m'occuper de mes
propres productions
parce que quand on fait ou vous même et
de l'amour qui se donnant dans le film
dans le script dans la production dans
dans le jeu d'acteur et je suis un
garçon aussi j'ai un jeune garçon que si
je fais je travaille pas tous les jours
mais quinze heures par jour je m'emmerde
et quand je m'emmerde choisi comme les
voilà voilà beaucoup d'énergie vous êtes
moyens non-violents rien de problèmes
lors il ya un autre problème c'est que
jean claude et anxieux jean-claude dit
je n'irai pas à 60 ans il a une
prémonition vous dites quelque 45 ans
physiquement c'est possible parce que je
travaille très dur je travaille très
très dur moi je respecte d'un gars comme
johnny parce que jena lee des il faut
une santé dans le cinéma dans le show
business
johnny c'est pas un enfant de choeur non
plus on le sait tous mais grâce à dieu
il a une santé superbe
alors il ya des acteurs qui ont une
santé et un autre en bonne santé et si
si grâce à dieu si j'ai une bonne santé
je peux aller très très loin mais je
travaille très très dur et ça paye après
les artères paye les avions et retour
les bazars dont 43 sont p 3
s'il vous reste trois ans ah ouais c'est
pas s'il trois ans ça a vite les femmes
ça vous fait il pas un peu ah et pour
l'instant ce traitement juste sur une
histoire ce que je vais faire je vais
essayer de rentrer sur le monde
médiatique dans le net on va annoncer un
film dans le net de chaque pays
puis on ira sur le web et puis on fait
avec des antennes et trendy opaque berne
rodéo elle le wild eyes in a wide band
chapeau alors on va laisser le wide band
et là deux voisins l'on pourra toucher
250 millions de bioux ouais ouais ça ça
c'est quelque chose de bien pour pour un
film de qualité avec les gens monde
entier les gens qui n'ont pas d'argent
il appuie sur un bouton
ils doivent pas attendre 40 heures pour
le download hockey parce que c'est fait
avec wiz on va distribuer les films avec
le téléphone après faire contre ça le
match brest d'où des toqués du 15 mai
quand on attend pas je peux pas attendre
le satellite
ouais ils dépensent trop d'argent ça
coûte des millions de dollars alors on a
trouvé un système grâce au net
c'est à moyenne ou faire du pognon sa
traduction
j'étais loin de penser qu'il y ait eu 6
ha non bien voilà jean claude van damme
aujourd'hui vous avez assez d'argent
pour vous arrêter de bosser nom assez
pour moi même passé pour les autres
parce que dans la vie il faut partager
ouais opus condor puisqu'on reçoit et
attention il faut pas
elle anime qu'en donne quand on donne
sans recevoir parce que quand on
construit des entités intimidante
identité les gros a dit et il faut il
faut oui j'ai commandé les enfants j'ai
fait ma vie j'ai roulé ma bosse j'ai
fait la cokerie des gens disent que j'ai
fait 4 6 7 bis je sais pas quoi on a
tous choqués alors tous alors après on
fait un point sur la vie alors combien
prometteuse un reste à vivre 1 45 67 ans
est par contre il faut faire quelque
chose de bien la vie l'âge et des femmes
qui m'aiment bien il ya des qui manquent
pas alors je me suis retourné bien il
reste peu de temps faire cela c'est 10 à
15 parce que de 40 à 50 ans on a recensé
après on devient un peu
fatigués n'ont jamais fait pour moi
alors ce qui se passe est curieuse pour
quand même à l'enjeu je prenais ma long
chez 20 minutes dans ma loge thierry
avec geneviève ja peu fatigué avec
jamais je m'assoupis un peu j'aime bien
les souches aime bien bonjour cher et si
tu les tarifs widi général et cela nous
laisse les gens allongés massage être
marié oui c'est incroyable cette fois
marie avec gladys qui était votre
troisième femme mais être marié avec
elle qu'est ce qu'elle est plus que les
autres parce que c'est un grand
séducteur quand même que vous récupérez
non j'allais sincère sur une mère de
famille elle est là elle est parfaite
elle est parfaite elle elle dit du mal
sur personne mais j'ai du mal à personne
elle prend votre enfant par exemple en
vacances c'était ton fils de tout à fait
aussi bien que mon fils et ma fille elle
m'a été envoyé par une force de la
nature qui s'appelle pour certaines
personnes dieu allah boudache et pas
comme on l'appelle est cette femme
s'occupe de moi et depuis qu'elle
redevenu dans ma vie mais je casse ah
bah oui